bonjour nouvelle édition de votre rendez
vous politique sur tv 78 voici le
sommaire de ce mois de mars
véronique côté millard la mer udi des
clayes-sous-bois ne se représentera pas
en 2020 elle jette l'épongé en coulisses
on se positionne déjà pour sa succession
son premier adjoint philippe guiguen
vient d'annoncer sa candidature et nous
expliquera pourquoi dans un instant mais
avant les municipales les électeurs se
rendront aux urnes dès cette année pour
les européennes un scrutin toujours
difficile en termes de participation le
mouvement les jeunes avec macron veut
mobiliser l son président dans les
yvelines marc lerouge est également
l'invité de cette émission et puis un
hommage hommage à andré damien le maire
de versailles durant 18 ans est les
responsables politiques étaient nombreux
à se recueillir lors d'une messe en sa
mémoire dans la cité royale began
bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau premier adjoint aux
clayes-sous-bois dès à présent candidats
pour 2020 vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi ce choix pourquoi l'annoncé a
dès à présent dans un instant auparavant
la direction versa et donc avec le
décèle 5 mars dernier de son ancien
maire andré damien il avait 89 ans
aurélien
[Musique]
jean louis debré gérard larcher ou
encore valérie pécresse
ils avaient tous côtoyé de près andré
damien et sont venus lui rendre un
dernier hommage en la cathédrale
saint-louis avocats mais aussi homme
politique l'homme décédé le 5 mars
dernier à l'âge de 89 ans fut le premier
magistrat de la ville de versailles de
1977 à 1995
l'une de ses réalisations marquantes le
sauvetage du marché notre dame
je crois qu'il versait mais aussi le
souvenir que c'est le maire qui a sauvé
le marché et donc chaque fois que les
versaillais bon sens le marché peut se
souvenir que maître damien a beaucoup
oeuvré pour la rénovation ce marché lp
si c'est une occasion de lui dire notre
reconnaissance comme élus locaux nous
savons bien que nous ne sommes que les
continuateurs de quelque chose qui a
commencé avant nous et il a marqué cette
ville d'une empreinte définitive une
personnalité qui aura donc marqué
l'histoire de la ville de versailles
de son côté la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse se
souvient d'un homme profondément
humaniste avec une très grande liberté
de ton
j'étais
un bébé d'amiens comme il y en a eu
beaucoup dans les yvelines c'est à dire
qu'il m'avait pris sous son aile et il
était avec moi au conseil d'état il
m'avait demi pied à l'étrier quand je
suis arrivée au département il avait eu
d'ailleurs le courage de me soutenir
mois la jeune femme entrée en politique
face aux pontes de son parti un homme
attentif aux personnes qui étaient dans
le besoin et qui ne manquait pas
d'humour comme l'a rappelé monseigneur
éric aumônier tout au long de la mer
[Musique]
voilà pour cet hommage qui a été rendu
nous allons continuer à parler des
municipales mais des municipales de 2020
on va aller un petit peu dans l'avenir
cette fois ci avec vos philippe guillem
vous résidez donc aux clayes-sous-bois
depuis une quarantaine d'années
professionnellement vous étiez salariés
notamment au sein du groupe airbus
et puis en 2001 vous rejoignez l'équipe
municipale maire adjoint aux finances
vous souhaitez poursuivre cette
expérience en revêtant cette fois ci les
sharp d'élus de merde principal édiles
pourquoi cette candidature tout d'abord
tout à fait pourquoi cette candidature
et pourquoi si tôt un an avant un envol
scrutin je pense qu'il faut se donner le
temps de préparer un programme qui soit
crédible vis-à-vis des clés siens et des
clés sienne je pense qu'il faut savoir
les écouter c'est fini je pense la
politique nous allons arriver avec un
programme tout fait il faut savoir se
mettre au niveau de toute la population
pourquoi me représenter
avec cet objectif de premier édile de la
ville parce que j'en ai encore envie
parce que j'en ai la possibilité
en terme de temps ce qui n'était pas mon
cas jusqu'à présent en tant qu'
effectivement et salariés est très actif
dans le secteur privé
ce n'était pas le cas jusqu'à présent
parce que j'ai toujours été fidèle à
madame côté millard et je porte son
mandat tout ce qu'elle a réalisé sur
cette commune depuis trois mandats mais
maintenant en plus fort du soutien d'une
majorité de mes amis au conseil
municipal
je me sens en position de d'assumer
cette fonction au service des clients
vous avez prévenu véronique côté millard
de votre candidature est-ce que vous en
avez discuté avec véronique côté millard
bien entendu était au courant de mon
souhait de me présenter aux prochaines
municipales
depuis quelques mois bien sûr bien
entendu elle qui a décidé de ne pas se
représenter a dit qu'aujourd'hui être
maire c'est difficile justement elle
était notre invité il y a quelques jours
écouté parce que vous préparer l'avenir
est ce que vous avez pensé à passer la
main avant la fin du mandat on le voit
dans certaines communes aussi des mères
qui qui passe un petit peu le relais ça
se fait souvent avant les élections est
ce que ce sera votre karma ma
préparation de l'avenir c'est d'aller
jusqu'au bout de mon mandat jusqu'au
dernier jour est justement de conduire
les maximum de dossiers auxquels nous
avons tous l'équipe municipale donc on
s'est investi et qu'on voudrait porter
jusqu'au bout attendez vous si votre
succession que non d'autant plus que
j'ai la chance d'être à la région donc
s'il de faire avancer des dossiers
et voilà est d'aller le mât dans le
maximum possible de notre engagement que
nous avons pris donc faso face aux
électeurs jusqu'au dernier tour et
jusqu'à la dernière minute et avec
toujours le même enthousiasme vous
soutiendrai néanmoins une liste pendant
la campagne l'année prochaine bah
écoutez j'ai pas la visibilité
nécessaire pour vous répondre je vais
parce que j'ai pas de cauna par
l'opposition mais la soirée
les candidats sur les lorraines déclaré
on l'a évoqué à l'époque une candidature
non déclarés dans sa famille politique
aujourd'hui c'est le caveau j'attendais
son soutien aujourd'hui c'est le cas je
j'espérais avoir son soutien ceci dit je
serais déçu si je ne l'avais pas mais
c'est une décision qui lui appartient
totalement
par contre ce que je peux ajouter ce que
véronique côté millard aura mon soutien
total jusqu'à la fin de ce mandat bien
entendu nous faisons partie de la même
équipe avec les mêmes projets vous allez
vous aussi travaillé jusqu'au dernier
jour comme un succès tout à fait tout à
fait au sein de votre équipe vous
évoquez le soutien d'une majorité de
votre équipe
tous les élus n'ont visiblement pas été
prévenus en tout cas c'est ce qu'on a pu
apprendre par un communiqué de presse
notamment certains membres de la
majorité qui disent avoir été surpris
vous leur répondez quoi je leur réponds
que je n'avais pas à prévenir l'ensemble
des élus il y avait un certain nombre
d'élus qui savait que j'allais me
déclarer qu'ils sont venus vers moi qui
m'ont dit maintenant nous pouvons nous
déclarer parce que nous avons un an à
travailler pour réaliser un programme
crédible vis-à-vis des des clés siens
d'autres élus le savait pertinemment ne
sont pas venus vers moi mais la porte
leur est ouverte pour que nous nous
menions à bien avec une équipe unie sans
aucun souci vous n'avez pas peur des
divisions
l'objectif c'est d'éviter les divisions
c'est aussi pour ça qu'avec le
conseiller départemental bertrand quo
car comme nous l'avons mis dans notre
dans notre conseiller nous y allons
ensemble pour le bien de la ville
aucun qui est aussi élu au sein de cette
commune et conseiller départemental qui
étudiaient aussi vous vous n'avez pas de
jeu carte politique je n'ai pas je n'ai
pas de carte politique toujours pas je
suis de sensibilité divers droite et
centre
je le revendique mais je n'ai pas de
carte politique ça veut dire que vous
allez mener une liste sans étiquette
qu'elle sera celle qu'elles sont les
hommes et les femmes qu'on va retrouver
sur votre liste
il y en aura une partie de l'équipe
actuelle parce que parmi ceux qui me
soutiennent il y en a qui veulent
repartir
d'autres qui soutiendront mais qui ne
repartiront pas et bien entendu nous
élargirons
avec de nouveau 'qe' les siennes et de
nouveaux chrétiens vous allez constituer
cette liste rapidement elle sera élaboré
jusqu'au dernier moment quel sac elle un
peu votre programme pour ce début de
campagne finalement elle va elle va
s'élaborer au fil du temps le programme
aux débuts de sets de cette campagne ça
va d'abord d'être à l'écouté des clés
sien c'est pour ça que nous avons prévu
déjà trois réunions sur site une le 5
avril une le 12 avril pardon une autre
le 14 le 4 juin et enfin une le 12 juin
dans chacun des quartiers de la ville la
première ayant lieu dans le quartier
nord de la ville à l'école coty donc le
17 le 17 avril elle revient sur votre
envie de poursuivre cette aventure
politique après votre vie
professionnelle je le disais tout à
l'heure véronique côté millard elle fait
partie de ces élus même si elle a été
élu plusieurs fois qu' aujourd'hui qui
aujourd'hui expliquait même à la
population que c'est compliqué d'être
mère et vous pour autant ça n'entrave à
rien non mais je partage la vie de
véronique côté millard on le veut on le
voit au quotidien
si on prend un sujet qui est d'actualité
par exemple l'intercommunalité
beaucoup de maires se plaignent du
transfert de compétences et de la
difficulté que nous avons aujourd'hui
pour répondre aux attentes et posséder
les moyens pour agir dépossédé des
moyens de tout à fait c'est exact donc
il faudra essayer de trouver un moyen de
mieux répondre
néanmoins vis-à-vis de
l'intercommunalité il ya aussi de très
très bons atouts surtout lorsqu'on est
dans une intercommunalité comme une
agglomération comme comme saint quentin
en yvelines
si j'en prends ne serait-ce qu'un
exemple nous sommes à l'heure actuelle
en train de travailler sur le plan
numérique des écoles qui grâce au
support de saint quentin en yvelines
grâce au support du département va nous
permettre de doter dans toutes les
écoles primaires de notre commune pour
chaque classe pour chaque élève une
tablette
ceci c'est un cetain c'est un réel
succès vous êtes aussi vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines les
clayes-sous-bois à la commune a rejoint
ya pas très longtemps finalement à cette
intercommunalité à 12 aujourd'hui vous
en êtes satisfait de cette
intercommunalité
alors moi moi qui qui est
une vision aussi venant de l'entreprise
j'apprécie toutes les compétences qui a
dansé cette intercommunalité
par contre quelques fois il ne faut pas
aller dans la sueur compétences et la
survaleur voilà c'est chacun sait que
dans les années à venir ce sera très dur
au niveau au niveau des ressources des
communes dont il faut savoir mettre au
juste niveau ce qui est nécessaire pour
pour les communes aura l'occasion de
reparler cette candidature pour les
municipales avec vous juste une toute
dernière question dans votre déclaration
de candidature vous mettez en avant
notamment le fait d'être européen mais
néanmoins profond est profondément
pardon attaché aux valeurs françaises
vous nous préciser pourquoi mettre cet
aspect là c'est aussi là on va voir ce
que parce que je pense que grâce à
l'europe depuis 45 ans nous sommes en
paix néanmoins dans chaque pays européen
nous avons nos propres valeurs dans nos
propres notre propre culture
ce qui ne nous empêche pas de pouvoir
bien vivre ensemble comme aux
clayes-sous-bois il faut que chacune des
générations puissent avoir le plaisir de
vivre ensemble dans notre belle ville
c'est comme le travail des clés au sein
de cinquante ans exactement même
principe doit être partagée pour le bien
de chacun
merci philippe big n 10 je vous en prie
saint-quentin-en-yvelines premier
adjoint des clayes-sous-bois aujourd'hui
candidat déclaré pour 2020 et puis on
rappelle aussi à l'autre candidature
déclarée c'est celle de l'opposition et
de nicolas hulot portera également une
liste de gauche cette fois ci merci à
vous je vous remercie la nouvelle ont
tourné la page des municipales pour
évoquer les européennes scrutin à le 26
mai de cette année il est d'ailleurs
encore possible de s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales jusqu'au 30 mars
avant de recevoir le prochaine invitée
regardez ce reportage de nicolas landry
il a suivi l'eurodéputé elle jean-marie
cavada à la rencontre des lycéens sur
versailles
ne demandez pas ce que votre pays peut
faire pour vous demandez vous ce que
vous pouvez faire pour votre pays
une célèbre phrase du président
américain john fitzgerald kennedy pour
sa conférence face à des lycéens
l'eurodéputé jean marie cavada a voulu
transmettre cet état d'esprit s'engager
pour la société si l'on veut que les
choses aillent mieux
il faut se lever de son fauteuil il faut
faire quelque chose pour le collectif et
leur première étape s'est naturellement
femmes et les élections européennes
parce que beaucoup des lois auxquelles
vous obéissez les haies les autres plus
de la moitié vit
de bruxelles alors il faut s'entraîner
pour son intervention au lycée
marie-curie l'union européenne étaient
au coeur des échanges ses valeurs son
fonctionnement mais aussi des
améliorations à apporter face à des
lycéens ayant leur regard sur la
question je pense que c'est important au
final qu'on soit unie autour d'une union
parce que ça rassemble les gens aient
forcément face à la montée en puissance
de la chine par exemple aujourd'hui et
la puissance américaine
finalement on est tous dans le même bain
dans le même bateau on est tous en
europe etc
et c'est important qu'on soit tous unis
en france on n'est pas non plus un pays
très grand donc en soi même si les
français font des efforts ce qui est
très important
ça ne suffira pas à sauver notre planète
malheureusement donc il faut qu'on se
soit sur une échelle qu'ils soient plus
grande
nos élèves sont déjà citoyen parce
qu'ils votent ou de futurs citoyens
il est hyper important qu'en dehors de
toute part tidianisme et prises de
position et un éclairage sur les enjeux
de notre société surtout en ce moment
pour pouvoir prendre des positions saine
sereine et éclairé jean marie cavada
devrait terminer son troisième mandat
sans le renouveler d'après sa promesse
initiale
sauf si une urgence absolue le pousse à
se représenter
marc lerouge bonjour bonjour bienvenue
en plateau vous êtes porte-parole des
jeunes avec mâcon alors saurez tout de
suite un j'insiste porte parole et non
président comme j'ai dit en introduction
des missions tout à l'heure engagé dans
la campagne des européennes on va aussi
à profiter de votre présence pour parler
encore un peu de cette campagne des
municipales aux clayes-sous-bois il se
trouve que vous êtes aussi élus de la
majorité sur elle les clayes-sous-bois
aux côtés de philippe duquesne qui vient
de devenir sur ce plateau hasard du
calendrier je vous avais invité sans
savoir qu'il y aurait les candidatures
des dessins et des autres dessins pour
l'instant en tout cas votre réaction par
la suite vous faites partie de ces élus
de la majorité qui n'étiez pas au
courant de cette candidature alors on
est on n'était pas au courant de
l'annoncé de la candidature on était
évidemment au courant que véronique côté
millard arrêtés sont son mandat elle
l'avait annoncé en 2014 lors des
élections donc elle ne jette pas
l'épongé
elle avait annoncé que c'était son
troisième et dernier mandat et
évidemment on savait qu'ils avaient des
élus qui allait se déclarer simplement
dans le communiqué qu on a envoyé avec
un certain nombre d'élus on a noté le
problème
la courtoisie et la loyauté la
courtoisie et d'annoncer à tout le monde
et la loyauté évidemment par rapport
notamment au maire de lui annoncer
elle était informée mais elle n'était
pas informé de la sortie du communiqué
de presse et ça nous semble être le
minimum
ça veut dire qu'il ya un début de
divisions au sein de cette majorité des
claies mais un risque pour la suite pour
un début de campagne
absolument pas pour le moment on est
tous concentrés monsieur guen l'a dit et
je retirais pas un mot de ce qu'il a dit
effectivement on est tous au travail
y'a pas de ya aucun problème sur ce
sujet là mais c'est une question de
forme
voilà sur la forme on aurait aimé que
tout le monde soit informé en même temps
et où des six possibles mère également
et après le reste bien lui appartient et
appartient aux personnes qui ont signé
ce communiqué avec lui une dernière
question à ce sujet pour être bien clair
est-ce que vous vous préparez votre
candidature
parce que je rappelle tout de même que
vous êtes engagés au sein de la
république en marche anciennement udi en
tout cas lui dei avec bertrand coquard
qui fait partie de la majorité qui lui
soutient philippe dit guen on est dans
un jeu politicien là on n'est pas dans
un jeu politicien bertrand kokari les
u10 il ya absolument aucun souci nous
enfin moi en ce qui me concerne et avec
un certain nombre de mes camarades udi
notamment tout lui d hygiène des
yvelines nous avions rejoint emmanuel
macron bien avant la campagne
présidentielle il n'y a pas d'histoire
de candidature ou pas déjà il ya une
commission nationale d'investitures chez
en marche donc toute personne qui
présenterait les décisions seraient mal
avisées parce que il ya beaucoup
d'autres choses qui se joue tant mieux
vous êtes candidat à la candidature
moi je suis pas candidat à la
candidature mais je suis candidat a
continué à travailler avec valerio
véronique côté millard et vous avez dit
une chose
oui je suis élu aux côtés de philippe
bielle mais pour l'instant je suis
surtout élus aux côtés de véronique côté
millard de la suite on aura bien le
temps à d'ici à l'année prochaine de
parler d'eux et des municipales ce pour
2020 ont pas parlé d'europe pour
l'instant car le scrutin c'est le à 26
mai inscriptions sur les listes
électorales jusqu'au 30 de ce mois ci 30
mars
vous vous dites il n'est pas question de
choisir entre plusieurs orientations
politiques c'est plutôt l'avenir du
continent européen
à l'échelle du monde qui se joue mais
c'est l'avenir du continent européen
parce qu'on voit qu'il ya des pays
aujourd'hui qui remettent en cause la
construction européenne qui remettent
même en cause pour certains d'entre eux
les valeurs principales les fondatrices
de l'europe on voit les pays comme la
hongrie on voit des pays comme la
pologne qui reviennent sur des droits
fondamentaux et sur des principes
fondateurs
et donc effectivement le risque c'est la
dislocation de l'europe et pour la
première fois depuis 2014 on l'a vu il
ya un pays qui a quitté qui a fait le
choix de quitter l'union européenne donc
c'est vraiment une question d'existence
et de survie pour l'europe et pour
autant les jeunes se mobilisent en
général assez peu pour ce scrutin vous
représentez vous êtes porte parole de ce
mouvement des jeunes avec macron comment
vous allez les faire revenir aux urnes
on va leur expliquer que l'europe s'est
pas seulement la construction européenne
qui s'est fait depuis les années 50 et
qu'il ya véritablement un choix d'avenir
mais que l'europe c'est extrêmement
quotidien que c'est extrêmement impliqué
dans nos jours dans ce qu'on voit sur
internet dans ce qu'on mange dans ce
qu'on fait quotidiennement et que
l'europe s'est pas seulement les pères
fondateurs et ce qui a pu se passer à
une époque où certains nos parents
n'étaient peut-être même pas nés c'est
aujourd'hui et c'est demain l'europe et
c'est extrêmement quotidien on peut pas
en même temps laisser aux extrêmes le
droit de dire que toutes nos règles
viennent d'europe et qu'on a perdu notre
souveraineté et en même temps dire que
l'europe ce n'est pas important
voilà donc l'europe c'est extrêmement
important et c'est le message qu'on va
vouloir passer aux jeunes et pas qu'aux
jeunes d'ailleurs cette année ce sera
peut-être encore plus particulier en
tout cas avec cette colère des gilets
jaunes qui s'est exprimé certains qui a
souhaité présenter des listes faire acte
de candidature et monopoliser un petit
peu les thématiques de scrutin se
démarquer de ces thématiques la éviter
un vote contestataire anti macron en
fait là aussi ce sera l'enjeu
l'enjeu il est il est déjà de faire
participer les gens il ya eu deux
événements il ya eu la première chose
avant le mouvement des gilets jaunes
l'automne dernier le parti la république
en marche a fait une grande marche
européenne dans toute la france il ya eu
cinq mille cinq cents événements il ya
eu 2 130 milles porte qui ont été
frappés 80 mille questionnaires qui sont
montés pour savoir ce que les gens
attendaient de l'europe pour savoir ce
que les gens attendaient des députés
européens de la commission européenne et
l'enjeu c'est de leur faire participer à
ce scrutin qui est fondamental et puis
le deuxième enjeu est évidemment vous
avez le président qui a envoyé une
lettre à travers un certain nombre de
médias européens c'est la première fois
depuis françois mitterrand je crois que
ça se fait et c'est l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir dire nous avons aujourd'hui des
messages à faire passer
nous français mais pas seulement il ya
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement
qui ont applaudi la démarche d'autres
qui l'ont critiqué pour une fois on a un
débat entre les pays européens
avant la campagne européenne ça se
déroulait simultanément dans les pays
est globalement ça ne sortait pas des
frontières là ça se répondent à travers
les frontières et c'est une excellente
nouvelle parce que ce sont des valeurs
qui vont non pas s'opposer mais en tout
cas se confronter avec un mode de
scrutin un petit peu différent
d'habitude il y avait des
circonscriptions voté par région par
grandes régions pour faire simple
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus qu'une seule
circonscription à l'échelle française
c'est la france ça rend encore plus
difficile le fait de faire campagne
ah non au contraire c'est plus simple
parce que vous pouviez avoir des
personnalités différentes dans les têtes
de liste par exemple en 2014
vous aviez alain lamassoure qui était la
tête de liste pour la droite
et puis vous pouviez avoir dans la
région grand test ou dans le sud une
autre tête de liste avec une
personnalité différente peut être avec
des nuances et là on va avoir une
politique nationale on va avoir des
programmes nationaux et on va vraiment
pouvoir aller programme contre programme
vision de l'europe contre vision de
l'europe sur tout le territoire au
contraire ça va être beaucoup plus
simple pour moi ces différentes têtes de
liste était aussi choisi en fonction des
territoires afin d'avoir incité au mieux
aux attentes de chacun là ce sera pas le
cas il faudra faire campagne de la même
manière partout mais nous on nous vous
l'ignorez pas on est un des derniers un
des derniers partis à ne pas avoir
officiellement de tête de liste mais on
a déjà commencé à présenter un programme
et des idées extrêmement concrètes
notamment par le biais du président est
donc belle l'enjeu c'est pas d'adapter
la tête de liste aux différentes régions
c'est de présenter un programme et des
idées qui va être adapté à ce que les
français attendent un programme cohérent
si je me base sur votre déclaration
pour mener cette campagne pour les
jeunes avec macron vous dites que la
france faut avoir moniz et l'europe dans
tous les domaines mais on se base sur
quelle référence celle de la france
justement sur la protection sociale par
exemple
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à faire un
compromis la démocratie c'est pas un
pays qui va mener et ou deux
éventuellement le moteur franco allemand
c'est très important un peu de pays
peuvent avoir peur de niveler aussi peut
avoir appris effectivement qu'ils
peuvent apporter avoir peur de niveler
l'idée ça peut être d'essayer d'avancer
sur les sujets sur lesquels on peut
avancer sur la défense européenne sur le
bouclier social sur tout un tas de deux
choses il ya des pays qui veulent
avancer
on le voit aussi sur la taxe gafa par
exemple il ya des pays qui ne veulent
pas avancer parce qu'elles ont des
avantages et qu'elles ont choisi d'avoir
une politique
et puis d'autres qui veulent avancer
différemment et donc l'idée c'est ça
c'est d'essayer d'avancer sur tous les
sujets sur lesquels on peut aller
ensemble ou en tout cas à réunir une
majorité et se faire entendre malgré la
sphère benalla le départ de nicolas
hulot les gilet jaune
christophe castaner en boîte de nuit
emmanuel macron au ski c'est un peu
difficile de faire campagne
il ya un petit peu de tout et enfin
entre la sphère benallal du président et
de la majorité est assez écornée
toujours en même temps il ya que ceux
qui font rien qui font pas d'erreurs
déjà pour commencer
après on va pas mélanger la sphère
benalla éventuellement les gilet jaune
on parle de deux personnes ou 3 et puis
les gilets jaunes un mouvement 4 quand
même une ampleur un peu importante
et puis le président de la république
qui part au ski pendant deux jours après
un voyage à l'étranger de quatre ou cinq
jours bon ce sont des choses en ont
absolument différente
il n'y a pas de bon moment pour partir
au ski il n'y a pas de bon moment pour
partir en boîte de nuit et je voulais
vous parler
j'avais en seriez peut-être passé et
ceci dit on se serait peut-être passé de
la polémique systématique qui consiste
chaque semaine à avoir une nouvelle
polémique mais c'est pas ça date pas des
manuels macron ça ça date d'il ya
quelques années
emmanuel macron lui avait promis de
mettre fin à ces polémiques haussière on
essaye de mettre fin à ces polémiques en
expliquant les choses
emmanuel macron avait un programme il se
trouve que les actes du programme et les
engagements sont pris et son se déploie
au parlement et c'est ça on essaye de
passer au dessus de la polémique
maintenant la polémique c'est devenu une
règle à la fois sur les réseaux sociaux
un système qui qui qui consiste à
critiquer tout le monde critique un peu
tout le monde et on en n'est pas
forcément exempt nous-mêmes et le but
c'est d'essayer de dépasser ça et
d'essayer d'avancer et d'essayer de
réformer ffi effectivement c'est pas
toujours facile de réformer mais c'est
le but au-delà de la polémique
concrètement sur le terrain il ya déjà
des réunions prévues des opérations de
tractage aller à la rencontre des jeunes
des moins jeunes pendant cette campagne
or la campagne elle a déjà commencé
puisque les tracts et les affiches sont
arrivés et ont commencé à être
distribuées
encore aujourd'hui on avait des jeunes
qui étaient devant des invités qui
étaient devant des lycées etc essayer de
mobiliser des citoyens
et puis nous en ce qui nous concerne
donc les jammes on va entamer par une
grande réunion publique qu'on va ouvrir
également avec des personnalités qui
seront dans la liste aux européennes
peut-être également des membres du
gouvernement donc on les a invités et on
va voir leur réponse le 6 avril à
versailles mais ça va être notre grand
événement de lancement de la campagne à
nous les jeunes avec maquereau et le
mouvement en marche dans les yvelines
également va faire la même chose et on
va aller comme à notre habitude partout
dans les villages dans les villes et sur
les marchés devant les gares et on va on
a cette chance d'être répartis sur tout
le territoire et on compte pas s'en
priver
enfin qu'il sera finalement assez
courtes toujours la campagne européenne
est toujours très courte beaucoup plus
courte que la campagne présidentielle
qui généralement commencé un an avant et
on rappel vous pouvez vous inscrire sur
les listes électorales je le précise en
général ça s'arrête au 31 décembre assez
jusqu'à la fin du mois de mars pour
pouvoir participer à ce scrutin il n'y a
qu'un seul tour le dimanche 26 mai merci
et marc leroux d'être un second revenu
sur ce plateau porte parole des jeunes
avec mâcon pour les yvelines c'est la
fin de ce set 8 politique on se retrouve
le mois prochain pour cette émission sur
cette antenne
[Musique]
le